[Musique]
bonjour pense avoir bien si vous
attendez donc vous allez la voir
super non franchement là où je peux dire
que l'été est à l'heure parce qu'en fait
c'est par là l'été je me dis bah quoi
quoi quoi comment ni vers ni vérité et
qu'elle étudie en fait j'ai toujours vu
voilà des films avec ma maman qui est
très cinéphile et les gars qui m'a
vraiment voilà a donné le virus quoi et
y en a un nom l'envi va dire l'envi
voilà ces wallons d ici quelques
semaines un vaccin contre la copie
pourrait être disponible mais selon un
récent sondage presque la moitié des
français n'en veulent pas et 24 %
répondent qu'ils n'accepteraient
probablement pas de se faire vacciner
19% certainement pas et ce phénomène
n'est pas nouveau
nous sommes l'un des pays les plus anti
vaccins d'europe voire du monde
beaucoup de gens me disent on à
atteindre vous fassiez vacciner pour
voir comment ça évolue
si effectivement vous n'êtes pas morts
nous ferons matinée s'appelle le bio
viseur c'est un projet parmi d'autres de
ces masques qui ressemblent plus à des
casque de cosmonaute ans à 4 longueurs à
grossemy c'est un peu ça c'est une tente
dans une tente trois secondes au dessus
de votre tête c'est un peu ça alors ce
qu'ils gagnent sympa c'est que vous avez
le côté transparente vous pouvez quand
même discuter avec les personnes en face
de vous forcer à la maison en poupe le
temps vu une famille très sympa uni
confinement silva ça peut plaire j'ai lu
il hier que stéphane bern disait au fond
ce virus il m'a permis de tuer toute vie
sociale et je me suis rendu compte que
je n'aimais qu'une chose c'était lire un
livre avec mon chien c'est le livre
philosophie de deux bagues atteint
larkin oui mais et ça va c'est bon c'est
pas que je comprends même pas ses mots
je te jure que je suis en train de
regarder je comprends rien
j'ai trouvé un mot probité ça veut dire
honnêteté
robiza c'est pas plutôt une probabilité
alors probité égale honnêteté vois je te
jure j'ai une question de leur lycée qui
platon alors que c'est l'écrivain le thé
adjectifs qui est à beth ce que relou
est à lure adjectifs qui est à beth ce
que relou est à lourd avec un t te vais
à 8 eb est relou l'eau manger du
chocolat rendrait plus intelligent
logements en hausse arrondie
mais en réalité des études sur le
chocolat il y en a des dizaines chaque
année alors sachez pêle-mêle j'ai résumé
le chocolat serait bon pour le coeur
serait source de bonheur augmenterait
l'espérance de vie favoriserait la
concentration et la mémoire ferait
baisser notre niveau de stress c'est ce
que montrent toutes ces études plus ou
moins sérieuses c'est oublié qu'on était
filmé et répété c'est impossible
j'avais il est sorti tout seul et si ça
ne suffit pas à vous convaincre qu'il ya
mon étude préférée celle qui montre que
plus un pays manche de chocolat plus il
obtient deux prix nobel ça aussi c'est
là une bonne raison pour aussi mais tout
de suite chocolat
je vous invite à écouter à queue à la
queue on aime sa préférée
avec une on peut parler par exemple de
coke
en pologne c'est pas très loin top le
mandant viril bien sûr en français mais
il ya aussi chez nous à nuces à nous et
glandeur tous les deux sont assez
proches un sens dans l'yonne
pourquoi lui pour faire des bisous des
six en direct de 9h30 à 11h30 sur rtl et
à partir de maintenant pour ceux qui le
veulent en simultané à la télévision sur
m6 où vous avez l'image en plus du son
regardez ce moment puisque je suis
actuellement en string en train d'animer
l'émission voilà si ça peut faire venir
deux trois téléspectateurs ne nous en
priverons pas donc ça va quand même fait
rire sauf que moi ma loge à côté de
celle de marie anne eric donc les
répondu ça m'excite plus les offenses et
professionnels
je n'en peux et éloignez vous des
réseaux sociaux et ça sera pas mal
exactement alors on va tous et même une
poignée de cas qu'ils font la loi et
parce qu'ils sont relayés par vaux sous
collègues qui font des petits papiers de
me relayer twitter c'est pas du
journalisme
nicolas dupont aignan a donc publié un
tweet dans lequel il soit je suis tu je
souhaite un bon courage à nos biathlètes
on compte sur vous pour nous faire le
plein de médailles écrit-il problème
il accompagne son tweet de la photo d'un
skieur alpin en pleine descente
autrement dit rien il s'est trompé de
sport ne fait pas n'importe quoi mais
fait que n'importe comment
le skieur qui l'a choisie par d'ailleurs
les couleurs suisses pas le bon pays pas
le bon sport il n'y a pas de médailles
en coupe du monde mais voilà on ajoute à
cela qui a pas de médaille pour changer
souhaite le plein de médailles bref à
tout est raté dans ce tweet ce qui lui a
valu des milliers de réponses me
cueillir sur twitter un des internautes
qui encourage l'équipe de france de
basket avec une photo des all-blacks
que s'était il passé jb dans ce dossier
s'il vous plaît puisque vous vous étiez
occuper de ça alors là aussi je vais
laisser la patate chaude également
partir en vacances un peu plus tôt je
peux négocier sert auprès de la
direction parce que là visiblement ça
m'a figuration ce n'est plus du
journalisme avait raison des toits que
ces incivilités du je pense qu'on est
trois aides c'est qu'on s'endort voilà
où il faudrait faire le vide dans la
tête personnes à genève
[Rires]
j'ai découvert un cas dont c'est que mes
pieds
c'est la même chose que les mais
j'arrive à récupérer des objets avec les
pieds c'est quand même incroyable
là ça se passait très bien tata brigitte
pourquoi tu m'as envoyé un message passé
il avait branché
je suis obligé m'arrêter maintenant
c'est foutu bah oui il passera pas
qualifiés tant pis pour lui allez au
revoir tata 1
alors on va laisser mariner tullow
opérateur
cette avocate évidemment dont vous avez
parlé dont nous avions pas de me faire
voyager parmi tous les morts restant de
ma vie cloud oui on a pensé que c'était
important
il le rappeler parce qu'après on pourra
je sais pas prendre de la drogue ne
semble pas sur ce nom maintenant on se
quitte avec ces images des suricates du
zoo de londres qui viennent de recevoir
leurs cadeaux de noël avec un peu
d'avancé un des grillons caché dans
cette boîte aux lettres réglions sont le
mets favoris de cette espèce de
mammifère également surnommé sentinelles
du désert voilà à demain